[Musique]
l'énorme capote rose sur l'obélisque de
la place de la concorde
il fallait le faire et ils ont fait il
était 9h ce matin acteurs étaient à sa
manière la journée mondiale du sida la
prévention est tellement mal fait en
france qu' il faut agir avec des gros
symbole c'est pour ça qu'on l'a en
capoter la place le message est simple
c'est sida que cette hécatombe à
concevoir la circulation ce poulain ça
fait deux mois qu'est ce que paris le
prépare et jusqu'à 7 heures ce matin le
secret avec bien gardé pas évident ce
manque d'aborder le sens de la place
sans alerter les packs de police mais en
quelques minutes les crs en cercle les
manifestants
[Musique]